[Music]  [Applause]  please  thank you andy please sit  andy sit down you told me you were gonna  insist three times and then i  should sit oh okay no andy  i think in the future i should just ask  twice okay please sit  and then reluctantly sit got it okay  okay these seats are terrible by the way  i don't know how i mean i were there no  porn theaters to rent  i mean this place is a dump you know i  looked into a porn theater  you did no we couldn't afford it so i  looked in and then scurried away afraid  the paparazzi would catch me  yeah yeah no i believe me i know the  porn theaters in this town  quite well yeah fantastic seating  uh good buffets yeah excellent buffets  yeah um and they owe me god knows i've  sent a lot of money their way over the  years  so i think but this largo was the best  we could do and for the money this is a  good theater i understand  motivated motivated yeah